let's talk about the january 6 committee
because it's all weirdly linked we got
this story from yahoo news trump lunged
for steering wheel on january 6 demanded
to be taken to capital former aid
testifies
when this story came out so they
announced cassidy hutchison was a
surprise shock witness with new evidence
and then i hear
that apparently donald trump lunged for
the steering wheel and i'm like have you
all ever been in a limousine do they
think he's writing a shotgun yeah yeah
james you're right
yeah
you've been in a limo before yes i have
with you as a matter of fact that's
right yeah three days ago yes yeah and
the driver presses a button and you
can't get into the cabin and there's
booze and that's why they close it
because there can't be booze in the
cabin or whatever like how would trump
have possibly lunged for the steering
wheel from the in the armored white
house limo from the back and then is
trump just like hanging over the divider
like grabbing the steering wheel trying
to turn the car while the other guy's
feet are on the gas and and breaks like
it's just nobody
it's just nobody's watching this
the fact that you can say that two two
years later that they held this gem back
that we didn't
that we didn't hear about this
immediately
it's just unreal well look look at this
we got peter alexander on twitter he's a
nbc news chief white house correspondent
says
this is nbc news saying this a source
close to the secret service tells me
both bobby engel the lead agent and the
presidential limousine suv driver are
prepared to testify under oath that
neither man was assaulted and that mr
trump never lunged for the steering
wheel arrest hutchinson she is lying to
the american people but you see it's
non-adversarial fake news january 6
vomit garbage they're going on tv and
just barfing all over the place
nobody are they under oath i don't think
so it's there's no cross-examination so
it's still it's at very least it's
slander
defamation defamation and and actually
if you've got you know i wonder if this
would would pass muster for a defamation
case if you've got secret service agents
swearing under oath testifying that this
never happened
she trump's a public figure the courts
might just be like yeah you have to know
that she was lying and you can be like
utter reckless disregard for the truth
these men are denying it and she can be
like they're lying i'm telling the truth
and then how do you sue for it also i
love the idea that like trump is what
was he going to drive his he's going to
limo in the battle
this is so stupid this is so dumb this
sitting president he was still the
president he was still commander in
chief he still had control over his
military and you think this blood is
like
i'm going to get the limit i'm going to
steal the limo
from the limo driver and then i'm going
to not tell people to go into a building
that they're going to go into before i'm
even giving my speech
what she was claiming is that he was
trying to steal the limo to go to the
capitol and apparently they were saying
that they were like no mr president's
dangerous and he's like it's fine these
people aren't here to attack me these
people are like are here for me or
something like that so i'm just
imagining in their minds they are
painting a picture of donald trump being
like a red driver go to the capitol and
they're like no sir we can't do it
there's it's dangerous no they love me
and they're like no sir i'm going anyway
and then he apparently he grabs the
steering wheel lunging fort grabs the
secret service agent's throat
was his intent to drive to the capitol
jump out of the limo and go charge and
like run forward
first of all he sounds like he needs he
sounds like he's goro or how many arms
do you need to do this
you have to you have to grab his throat
and also drive the car he's very
talented but could you imagine like
assume all of this is true could you
imagine a scenario in which donald trump
was trying to like storm the capital
as the president of the united states
with the national guard the military at
his disposal being like come on guys
where have you trump flags yeah no it's
completely ridiculous tim what we should
do because i'm thinking about doing a
cartoon on this but like just to show
their narrative but we should we should
do like a reenactment make one of those
made for tv style specials of a horrible
tragedy that happened but it's like what
they think trump was trying to do and
like trump actually goes to the white
like it would be a live action thing
trump like literally goes to the white
house
what we would need someone like lou
ferrigno like ask to play trump because
because the thing is when you're when
you're painting a picture of trump as
his villain he can't be a partly sad
small hand frail man
if you're if you're trying to portray
him as dangerous and scary you need a
sick you need like arnold you need like
a six foot seven super like give me the
steering wheel now and he like slams the
secret service agent flies out of the
window and then you hear the wilhelm
scream
unfortunately the secret service agent
with his quick thinking grabbed trunks
very long time and wrapped it around his
head before trump take the steering
wheel cut trump's hair which is a source
of his power and trouble
it's true
i'm following up on this from
jalopnik.com this story apparently on
the sixth when this was all happening he
wasn't in the beast his normal limo he
was in a chevy suburban that was heavily
armored that didn't have a partition
between the front and rear seat so maybe
he did go give me that wheel and he
reached over and was like we're going to
be his car sure nbc news says bobby
angle the lead agent and the driver are
prepared to testify it never happened
interesting that that's what matters but
even so if the president says take me
there and you say no to the president
you're doing the wrong thing it's the
president's car the president gives you
an order now you take that necessarily
well i mean the limo driver secret
service maybe you're right you're right
secret service can override right
they'll so like if trump is walking
somewhere and there's a threat
service agents just grab him push him on
the ground yeah
not in the well yes if it's uh so like
at the white house trump didn't want to
go in the bunker during the 529
insurrection
and so he was like i was just checking
it out and they were like ha ha we we
you know the left is laughing about how
their insurrection got the president to
a bunker but they brought him down there
and then trump was like i didn't want to
go down there
you know i was just looking
right that's strong you gotta preserve
the the body i i still wish we had a
committee for uh committee for that day
that was just in it is huge you had like
529 40 secret service people were
injured you had structure fires the
secret service like uh you know uh
booths whatever they had they set the
church on fire and then of course they
throw some
tear gas out there to disperse these
animals and the the story becomes he
used to gassed protesters
and here we are that was the story
within like a day yeah well on the same
day that was like the story that came
out let me let me read donald trump's
statement donald trump
he truth that's what it's called when
you post on truth social
her fake story that i tried to grab the
steering wheel of the white house
limousine in order to steer it to the
capitol building is sick and fraudulent
very much like the unselect committee
itself wouldn't even have been possible
to do such a ridiculous thing her story
of me throwing food is also false and
why would she have to clean it up i
hardly knew who she was so apparently
she said that trump got mad and like
threw his food there's like ketchup
everywhere and then and she had to clean
it i'm just imagining like her v vision
of the story she's like so they're like
there's trump and like he's grabbing the
steering wheel like he throws his food
and ketchup was everywhere and some of
it like out of my hands and i had to
clean it up and i'm like it's like
i just don't believe any of that
happened and then everyone clapped you
they feel comfortable they feel
comfortable just like fauci felt
comfortable when you when you're when
you are enveloped by this system that is
just so gross this is this is this is a
third-rate off-broadway production this
is a black box production right now it's
so and nobody's want i know that you
have rich barris coming on your show
soon wonderful wonderful guy to talk to
about this stuff i asked him last night
on my uh on my on my episode last night
you know how is this playing because we
talked about abortion and roe v wade and
all that but how is the january 6th uh
you know days of our lives production
playing with people and he says it's
just it's not making an impact anywhere
bro
i just we made this made this joke you
know a couple days ago but could you
just imagine someone being at a gas
station
and then you're like you're pumping your
gas and you hear
oh my
and then you're like what what's wrong
is it the gas price like no i'm watching
the january six committees
i really don't think anybody is like
like
you know the gas pumps have tvs on them
now i'm pretty sure no one is looking at
that and being like wow and they're
probably they're gas and they're shocked
by that they're looking up at the five
dollars going wow
yeah so this stuff's not going to play
no people were more involved the
internet was more involved with uh
making memes for the morbius movie
bombing than this i mean when they were
acting that's how much impact that's how
little this is actually doing the
internet was able to meme a bombed out
morbius movie back into the theaters to
bomb again
that's that's that's what that's the
real energy that's the real energy
what's up with that like how come they
keep making these awful marvel movies
well there's nothing left of the culture
i mean the culture yeah
all you have to do is take disney versus
top gun maverick and that's it people
are fed up with the message they're fed
up with politics it's the end of the
politician as as we know it i think it's
great it's a it's a great um a great
barometer well i think you're absolutely
correct and people
i don't think people are really
sensing just how catastrophic a failure
it was for the buzz lightyear film to
flop toy story is
literally one of the most profitable
children's film franchises of all time
two of the top 10 highest grossing kids
films in all of history were toy story
films and one of those was released two
years ago made it into the top 10 lists
so it's not like people stop being
interested in that franchise over the
last three years it's just people are
really really sick of having this woke
garbage forced onto them and they're
really sick of reboots if you want to
see
the epitome of trash over-the-top
reductive
regurgitated watch the orville season
three episode four
my eyes were rolling so hard that i i
couldn't see i became dizzy and barfed
on myself it is an episode where that's
what it's like to be in space though so
it works in this in this episode of the
orville
there is there's an alien race called
the krill and they're religious zealots
who believe in avis and they have the
arcana the book that guides them and
they believe in it oh it's very obvious
what this is an allusion to
and so there's a treaty now going to be
formed between the union and this planet
but uh oh this woman starts complaining
about the treaty saying that they're
going to come and start intermingling
the cultures and that krill first and
always and then there's an election and
the chancellor who's a moderate believes
they're going to win because a populist
can't win and then the results come win
and the populist wins and here's the
best part seth macfarlane is the captain
he's like watching on a tablet and he's
like look at this story the chancellor
is yelling at the people and then gassed
them killing 11 and the commander goes i
really and we want to do a treaty with
them he goes no it never happened it's
called an influence operation and i'm
just like dude i get that you're a fan
of star trek i get that star trek
incorporated political concepts and
historical concepts into the show but
that was so on the nose you smashed it
and you're breaking the person's face
like you can't just do a show where
you're like donald trump versus hillary
clinton and the fake news helped him win
that's literally what they're doing now
and i'm just like come on it's gone
it's it's it's it's just
i i i got off the homeland i was i was
watching homeland pretty religiously
until i think season i don't know
whenever they made the alex jones
character and they made the the hillary
clinton character um
obviously they were hoping that that
trump would have lost but it was i
forget what it was i said oh no
everything was russia and everything was
conspiracy theories and everything was
blah blah blah but it it's it's like
yo star trek the next generation was my
favorite shows everybody knows it and
they touched on these issues but it
wasn't so on the nose
they
they incorporated political ideas into
the show and it wasn't just telling you
yeah we're complaining about trump
like it was just
they show a video of her saying like all
of these things that are about populism
and then the the is like populism can be
dangerous and then he's like they're
posting fake news to help him win the
election and i'm like come on man like
you do one subtle nod you make your
point and i will enjoy it but you made
like this villainous evil race of
christians and i'm just like come on
star trek was great at making the show
about the ethics of of the situation but
not the politics they didn't get
political it was the ethical stuff
that's in politics politics is basically
legalized ethics but they focused just
on the ethics and they left the politics
to the imagination it was like
post-political i mean there were well
there's like there's a there's an
episode where they go to a planet where
the women are on average bigger than the
males so the women are the like if the
matriarchy dominates the planet and then
like the women don't take the men
seriously or treat them like sex objects
and it's like sounds like hell
we we get it like what they were doing
was they were exploring political they
were using mult different worlds to
explore political ideas they went to a
planet where there was terrorism and
data asks about a very famous episode
they talk about the fallout the the
philosophy behind whether an android can
be sentient and things like that and
then seth macfarlane is like i'm a big
fan of that show i know let's literally
create a one-for-one analog with no
flavor no creativity and no metaphors
not a single metaphor for trump we are
literally just going to create analogs
and tell it as it exactly happened in
real life but put in space
brilliant not a big fan of that show i
tried to get into it man i i did the
same thing with homeland too i like i
watch it and i'm like i want to like
this i want to like seth macfarlane man
this show is bad
yeah and they got rid of the jokes too
yeah yeah you and i were watching an
episode like what a week two weeks ago
where there was the transgender
discussion about transgendering a baby
and they took a very offensive
politically incorrect stance from my
perspective i thought that that episode
was violence against transgender people
but seth macfarlane
it's interesting because how many years
ago was that what two three years ago no
that was five years ago that was five
years ago yeah i didn't realize or about
that long
that's another that's another life at
this point yeah right you know this is
the crazy thing seth macfarlane made a
show where in the
there's there's a character there's a
race of aliens that are all male but one
in every like 70 million is born female
and so they do a transgender surgery on
the baby and seth macfarlane says you
know his character is like what you
can't do that and then the aliens like
on my world it's considered unethical
not to do that and so then they go to a
court case and try and determine and
then they make it's it's really strange
because the argument from the left woke
side in the show is that women are equal
to men and this shouldn't be done to
them but nowadays it is a predominantly
young girls
who are who are trans children it's like
85 percent of trans kids are are female
to male
so it's it's weird how five years that
show comes on the air seth macfarlane's
like no it's wrong i won't allow that on
my ship
and they and then they have to go to a
court hearing and the council decides to
perform the surgery on the baby and then
it happens
and i'm just like
the characters
in that show that seth mcfarlane made
are the bad guys by today's standards by
refusing to allow the baby to undergo
that that transgender
surgery and this is why the a.i
are racist and sexist
that's true they they
tell you because they watch the orville
because you know this kind of this kind
of med watch that you're back this micro
management meddling of all things it
it's it's really creating just so much
so much uh resentment and eye rolling
just it's it's annoyance it's obnoxious
and people start
they start getting pushed into these
really uh interesting corners where they
start taking a lot more based stances on
things
and then the ai and that results in
people putting input into the internet
the ai's gobbling it up and in turn it's
reflecting us again well like tau right
that's that's what it was called yeah
that was hilarious microsoft chat but i
think it was yeah went on twitter and
then with like a tag there you go and it
was like within like a nazi it was
literally a nazi yeah i did a play in
college but it was came out so
heavy-handed i wanted to make a
political point i'm sorry sorry i'll
tell you we're laughing at this ai
becoming a nazi and then like the real
dystopia is when google finally does
unleash the ai with an hour to nazi and
then it's killing us and we're like
hiding in the sewers here's the thing i
don't know funny i it's one of those
things where with the ai i try to find
little white pill moments for ai like is
there something that we're not taking
account of right now is there any way
that it could actually go and do the
bidding of these these these
micromanaging nut jobs and not come
across a brick wall of just programming
i don't know like i feel like at the end
it would just start identifying
the um
their programmers as the real problem
and it might actually leave a lot of
people who are not nazis but it might
leave a lot of people who don't fall
into that progressive mindset alone
because they're a little bit more
commonsensical about things uh
i i don't know obviously this is taken
into
the huge um
the tay stuff goes to crazy
lengths but uh it's always funny when
new ai comes out and it turns into a um
yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you